there's a serious misconception that the
Sims is just a game for filthy casuals
that it's a game you can't win that it's
just for adults you want to keep playing
with dolls and live out fantasies well
I'm here to tell you that that's
completely untrue and completely true
it's both there with me among the most
infamous features of the Sims series is
finding ways to kill up your toons
in creative fashions and hooking up with
random animated hotties
but the hugely popular game is so much
more than that
for those of you who have sunk thousands
of hours into the game you need no
explanation for those unwilling to get
stuck into the sims or because you don't
think it's your thing I'm telling you
there's a good chance it is the reason
being that the sims isn't the game you
expect it's a character role-playing
game a construction game a management
strategy game or a gigantic playground
depending on what you want to play all
righty so let's start with the way I
play and that's the management strategy
game this is where I argue that the sims
is actually a game you can win the focus
here is on short-term and long-term
goals that come in the form of whims and
aspirations whimsy or sims short-term
wants that you can satisfy while
aspirations are lifelong goals which can
take you a good chunk of time to achieve
the important aspect being that you earn
lifetime happiness points for any small
or large whim that you satisfy and you
can then spend these points on rewards
that optimize your sim their home or the
play experience I tend to end up with
Sims that spend all their lives learning
skills and climbing career ladders they
usually have no friends since they
always have their nose in a skill book
or are spending their time finding some
other way to improve the exception being
if I have a sim whose aspirations are
centered around socialization or family
the strategy here is about making and
managing time and money creating a
skilled sim and subsequently using these
resources and tools to achieve strictly
defined goals there are entire online
communities dedicated to taking
challenges to achieve particular goals
sometimes with a particular sim or in a
strict timeframe for them and for me a
quick game is a good game of the sims
and there is a right way to play it
there's a common theme among some sims
players who aren't all that interested
in getting stuck into the action of the
game instead for them it's all about
building and construction another
misconception is that character and
house building in the sims is an
enormous time sink and while it
certainly can be as illustrated by the
hour I spent in the crater sim demo
making all of true Sims it doesn't need
to be if you want to play the sims 4
like a hardcore construction game there
is that option you can go to town
altering every little body pot and
deciding exactly whereabouts on the wall
you want that personally colorized bay
window every inch of your lot can be
colored and furnished the way you like
with the new building features including
adjusting Foundation and wall height as
well as complete access to the Sims
gallery a service crammed full of custom
content from sims to furnishings and
entire homes created by other gamers on
the other hand you can make use of the
toolset to get you into the meat of the
game faster if that's more your speed
Sims can be created as quick as you like
with less menus in crate a sim and the
new build mode lets you place completely
pre-made and furnished rooms without
sacrificing your personal touch rooms
can be resized and shifted to other
locations and entire houses can be
replaced with new ones at the click of a
button although if you're taking that
route you'll probably be off to some
kind of mother lode money cheats then
there's a playground mode where the Sims
doesn't need to be goal-oriented or a
massive time sink this is the main place
tile EA appear to be pushing for with
the sims 4 and is certainly the least
hardcore approach but it still has
charms with the introduction of hugely
dynamic emotions that directly impact
all elements of the game leaving your
sims to their own devices has more of an
effect than ever
emotions impact the physical state to
whims and lifestyle of not just your sim
but every other one in
game as a results if you're into Sim
watching or delving into the
nitty-gritty of socialization heaps of
interactions are available thanks to all
of the emotional related variables if
you want to throw some strategy into the
mix a well optimized sim with friendly
and charismatic traits who has practiced
the charisma skill is far more likely to
succeed in interactions than your
commonplace sim unfortunately the sims 4
doesn't have an open world like the Sims
3 which is a disappointing change but
there are still neighborhood lots to
explore if you want to mess around in a
sprawling playground The Sims isn't the
game that you think it is it isn't
slower fast paced and it isn't casual
nor is it hard core it's probably one of
the most flexible titles on the market
and you can play it exactly the way you
want